tons and tons of people are upset that
the covid relief bill
has a bunch of extra spending in it pork
barrel spending on things unrelated to
covid relief why should a covid bill
have earmarks for
higher education in foreign aid it
doesn't make sense well
it actually does because this isn't
really a covid bill for various
procedural reasons i'm not going to go
into this is actually a spending bill
that happens to have a
covid bill attached to it this is a bill
that funds the
us government through september of 2021
1.4 trillion dollars to keep the
government running and for various
arcane procedural reasons it made
sense to add the 900 million dollar
covid relief bill onto the 1.4 trillion
dollar spending bill so this isn't a
covet bill with a bunch of extra
spending it's a spending bill with a
bunch of extra covid stuff and if you'd
like even more legal analysis check out
my real law reviews where i
tackle all the legal news of the day and
i'll see you in court